uh so potential spoiler for a Deadpool  three I don't say potential like it it  is a spoiler but like it's also going to  be a major part of the marketing and it  kind of now already is so if you're  trying to avoid this good luck but  that's your warning so Ryan Reynolds put  out a thing basically in a very Ryan  Reynolds fashion uh talking about  Deadpool 3 and basically dropping that  Hugh Jackman will be returning his  Wolverine and  yeah that tracks that makes sense I  honestly think it's about the one way  you could get Hugh Jackman to come back  for one more time and it is explicitly  stated to be one more time and in  addition to that it's about the only way  that someone like me would actually kind  of be okay with him coming back after he  very clearly signed off on the part in  Logan bringing him back for something  irreverent silly comedic like with  Deadpool  yeah I think that's a good fit I think  that's going to be a lot of fun I'll be  interested for a proper teaser